[Musique]
lorsque le soleil se couche sur les
Nogues à la Mi-Carême d'étranges
créatures que les lieux pendant une
semaine de drôles de personnages masqués
vont de maisons à maison pour boire et
fêter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en poussette pendant la petite école
qu'on a regardé pas assez mon grand-père
mon père tout de suite
[Musique]
arcostumés le jus consiste à deviner qui
se cache derrière chaque masque
c'est qui l'homme
un rayon dette Martin Papineau ça c'est
les deux députés
la tradition veut que le masque une fois
dévoilé reçoit un verre ou deux
peut-être trois
[Musique]
c'est la première fois ça coupe l'hiver
en deux
[Applaudissements]
le bon coup de folles
les premières fêtes de la Mi-Carême ont
eu lieu dans la France du Moyen-Âge pour
donner une pause à la rigueur du jeûne
liée au carême aujourd'hui elle est
encore célébrée à la mi-mars entre
autres aux Îles de la Madeleine et un
attache Quan pour la Mi-Carême de l'île
aux Grues une île de 114 résidents
situés à l'est de la ville de Québec et
tout près de Montmagny les insulaires
prennent la fête très au sérieux
Edith Russo et natif de l’élo-grue avec
son équipe elle a passé 278 heures à
confectionner des costumes
que j'adore ça cette année c'est le fun
parce que après la pandémie il y a eu un
arrêt puis moi je suis très intéressante
d'avoir la fébrilité des gens puis c'est
vraiment
pendant le MI carême il faut se déplacer
en avion pendant quelques minutes pour
se rendre à l'île aux Grues la fête fait
doubler la population même des jeunes
qui ont quitté l’île veulent perpétuer
la tradition
on veut encourager l'île à continuer
cette tradition là puis il a fait encore
on aime ça
l'ami carême c'est terminé dimanche
dernier à l'île aux Grues après un repos
bien mérité ces créatures masquées
reviendront en force l'an prochain ici
[Musique]